here now stephen miller america first
legal founder and former senior adviser
to president trump stephen it's always
good to see you this is really a very
sad story and you know i can't help but
think
that but for
the refusal of joe biden to create some
kind of regularity at the border that
this is his fault
it is absolutely his fault because joe
biden has sent the message to the world
that if you come to the united states
illegally you will get in the result of
that decision
tragically heartbreakingly are incidents
like this because people are coming in
record numbers and risking their lives
in many cases making the treacherous
journey and it's the heroes of our
country who have to risk their lives to
save them this would all stop tomorrow
if he just returned to the trump policy
of detain and deport break our laws the
law is enforced and you go home you know
the amazing part of it stephen is that
he has the house
the senate and the oval
why doesn't he do something about the
broken immigration system i got to tell
you i'm tired of hearing them say it's
broken immigration it's not broken
they're not following the law and all of
a sudden the law is broken or the
system's broken this is just this is
lunacy it will only get worse as this is
a rush on the border
their border policy is exactly the same
as what soros prosecutors are doing in
our cities right which is they are
unilaterally suspending enforcement of
the law and giving criminals free reign
immigration enforcement is law
enforcement and by saying that you will
not be deported what they are saying is
the laws of the united states will not
be enforced donald trump fixed the
system by restoring consequences for law
breaking
joe biden smashed the system into dust
by allowing everyone to break the law
with impunity well and that that
impunity i mean i call it privilege i
call it criminal privilege you know i
call it immigrant privilege right now uh
the people who are coming here illegally
have to hire a lawyer they have to you
know speak the language they have to you
know
give their you know
their uh honesty to the united states
i'm i'm missing the word there uh swear
allegiance to that it's such a loyalty
to the country
and and none of this is happening and
they're being flown into the interior of
the country faster than they're coming
in and then you know now they're saying
well you know it's not fair you
shouldn't be sending them to the
interior what should we be doing with
them
the only solution the only solution is
to end catch and release which is the
one thing that joe biden will never do
since his goal is maximum illegal
immigration every choice he's made from
terminating mpp to terminating the safe
third agreements to terminating every
historic reform donald trump put into
place has been to get more illegals into
the country and that's why my
organization america first legal is
suing joe biden along with the great
state of texas and attorney general
paxton to stop the recision of title 14
your organization is great but my
question is this and i only have a few
seconds left what is joe biden's end
goal here just to let everybody into
america until when
you're well you're witnessing it until
all of the country resembles the same
political experiment that took place in
california that is ultimately their
belief their design and their objective
they think that having massive
uncontrolled illegal immigration will
make this country a more liberal more
left-wing less conservative country
that's their belief that's their plan
and they're playing it through and all
the people dying are just collateral
damage oh sad how sad
thank you stephen miller always good to
have you on and thank you for the work
you're doing hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else